the las vegas raiders firing defensive
coordinator paul gunther abruptly last
night
sims surmised and i agreed with him
something had to have happened we just
had the mark columbo
joe judge incident november of this year
where
judge quickly fired colombo and it
turned out there was an incident between
the two of them it just seemed too
sudden it seemed to abrupt
but i'm told and i've seen nothing to
contradict this that it was just john
gruden calling up gunther saying we're
going in a different direction and
gruden today said
i really feel for the best interest of
this team right now we need a new voice
we need somebody who has a different
perspective a different approach rod
marinelli
takes over for the next three weeks i
don't know that it
increases the chances of the raiders
getting to the postseason
and i don't know how much of this is
really gunther's fault they just don't
have the players they've
skewed the spending this year heavily
toward offensive players a lot of guys
who haven't worked out and aren't there
the defense didn't get the same
commitment of resources and this is a
team that held the browns to six points
this is a team that beat the chiefs that
beat the saints it's not like they shut
them down but they still outscored them
the defense has to do
its thing to win those games and really
of all their losses the only loss to an
inferior team
a clearly inferior team was lost to the
falcons they had six turnovers in that
game so this one
surprised me and i don't know that
especially with only three days now
to get ready for a thursday night game
against the chargers this is going to
make a difference this has potential
disaster written all over it
for the raiders defensively on thursday
night shireen
yeah mike i saw this coming the day they
hired rod marinelli
because we know they go back to the
tampa bay days rod marinelli was the
assistant head coach
in tampa under john gruden when they won
their super bowl and so
i knew when he hired him this was
eventually going to happen and i think
this is more about next year probably
than the rest of the season just so
rod can call the shots and it's not
going to surprise me a bit if chris
richard gets a call and says hey come
join me
in las vegas to be a defensive assistant
or whatever they call them now to to
help out just for the rest of the season
to see what they can do chris richard
sitting at home waiting for a job
and was of course with rod marionelli in
dallas the last couple years
but i tell you the beginning of the end
mike was that
second chief's game when the raiders
scored late
minute whatever was left minute 40 some
odd i think was left on the clock
and we all knew what was going to happen
and chiefs go right down
and score that was kind of the end for
paul gunther i got a call from somebody
in the raiders organization that next
week saying
now do you believe how bad our defense
is and i said
yeah i get it that that was awful that
you didn't do come even come close to
stopping and i realized it's patrick
mahomes but you didn't come close to
stopping
but it is personnel you're exactly right
since paul gunther got there they ranked
last in sacs
lasting takeaways but they don't have
the players and you look at the failures
they've had the pj halls and those type
of
guys they drafted that didn't work out
it's a failure as much to get the talent
in there
over the past few years as it is on what
paul gunther said but i'm with you
i don't think it makes that much
difference this year but i do think it
was a move for next year
one of the problems this week they waved
defensive tackle daniel ross to create a
spot for trent brown when he emerged
from merged from the covet 19 reserve
list
and they were confident that ross would
slip through waivers and they would be
able to resign him
and uh he was claimed by the jaguars
so that blew up on them and at one point
yesterday for my understanding is i
haven't looked at the film my
understanding is
for extended stretches of the game when
the starting defensive tackles got tired
as they tend to do because they are
large men it was
chris smith a 266 pound defensive end
playing nose tackle against the
indianapolis colts which
is not going to work especially against
that team with that power they have
in the interior of the offensive line so
that's that for paul gunther
we'll see what rod marinelli can do
there are some folks out there
advocating wade
phillips remember remember what's going
on in
uh um dallas you you can't bring in
somebody that runs a completely
different defense
if you don't have the personnel for him
either so i don't i would be stunned if
wade phillips all of a sudden rides in
on a white horse to try to save
the raiders defense marinelli's the guy
they'll see what they can do and like
you said shireen this is the setup for
next year and and to see where it goes
from there hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports